great hello my name is scott weiner i'm
going to be discussing advanced concepts
in opioid stewardship today thank you so
much for attending this talk
i'm the director of the opiate
stewardship program at the brigham and
women's hospital in boston it's called
brigham comprehensive opiate response
and education our b corps program also
the director of our program in emergency
medicine health policy and public health
i'm an associate professor of emergency
medicine at harvard medical school
i have no financial conflicts of
interest to disclose
the objectives today are going to be
just high level how you create opioid
guidelines and how they can inform
metrics dashboards and clinical decision
support
i then want to take a deep dive into
three separate advanced opioid
stewardship concepts
including the scope of post-operative
overprescribing of opioids and how to
implement guidelines to address it
the second will be to identify
challenges and opportunities for
implementing a high-dose opioid tapering
program something which has been a big
challenge for a lot of health systems
and the fourth is to describe an
innovative model to address substance
use disorder treatment at a hospital
of course if you're attending this
course you already know the statistics
well
but it's just been devastating this past
this past year in particular
and we've seen increases in
overdose-related deaths for the past
many years
and then we thought we hit a peak around
2018 or so and then of course covet hit
and we hit a record number of
overdose-related deaths in 2020 about 93
000 lives lost about two-thirds of those
were from opioids and we know that was
about a thirty percent increase year to
date by the most recent data from the
cdc
absolutely tragic
and we also know that a lot of us that
work in hospitals and health systems
really do feel a pressure to do
something to fix it to address this
issue
it comes from our patients that want our
help comes with our from our clinicians
that need guidance
comes from the community who's looking
to us
and not infrequently it's coming from
the government who imposes certain
regulations for us that we need to
follow regarding opioids and other
substances
now hopefully you do have an opiate
stewardship program in your hospital i
was actually just involved with another
talk and i learned that about 40 of
hospitals actually have an opioid
stewardship program so if you don't have
it yet get on it we actually put this
paper in the joint commission journal on
quality and patient safety in 2019 and
it's really a cookbook to describe how
you can pull together a team and make
this happen please do look that up we've
also got a website which is
bcore.brighamanwomens.org
and we've really worked hard to just
make as much as we can open access we
put a lot of guidelines and documents on
there feel free to use whatever you'd
like for your health system i find this
is this is something where the more we
share the more we learn from each other
that's really the spirit of this
there's kind of three main phases to
what needs to be done for opioid
stewardship in my opinion
the first is creation of system-wide
guidelines and for us we created two
separate documents one is for acute pain
and one's for chronic pain
and what we did is we took guidelines
such as the 2016 cdc guidelines for
treatment of chronic non-cancer pain we
took what was required for our state
laws and we put them together and
created documents and guidance that our
clinicians can use
we found that it was helpful to do this
because it really did set the
expectations both for the providers
and particularly for patients because
with patients that have have pain issues
if you're withholding opioids for what
for whatever reason because you want to
try and use non-opioid pain relief which
we know is evidence-based a lot of times
patients just don't want to feel like
they're being treated differently and so
part of the guidelines are to
standardize our treatment standardize
the care that we offer to our patients
it's also protective for the hospital
i'm hearing more and more cases where
hospitals are named in suits from
patients that had adverse outcomes after
opioids this shows that the hospital is
dedicated to to using those medications
responsibly
once you have guidelines the next step
is to make metrics and reports and
things that are actionable
for us we created a whole opioid
dashboard it's got ambulatory care
emergency department care and surgical
care
guidelines in there for ambulatory care
we were able to look at the numbers of
opiate prescriptions per 1000 patient
visits that was helpful for us to
address outlier practices within our
system
in the ed we look at things like the
percentage of patients who are leaving
with opioid prescriptions the numbers of
pills per prescription
and we've been able not necessarily to
reduce these numbers but to really
tighten the means so we're not we don't
have such uh such outliers just the
practice is a lot more consistent now
and finally surgical i'm going to talk
about at length a little bit later in
this talk
once you have metrics and reports then
you can create clinical decision tools
these are just a couple of examples that
we have one of them warns you if you've
reached more than 90 more few milligram
equivalents per day
another one reminds you if you don't
have an opiate treatment agreement on
file for patients that are on chronic
opioids
we have other ones that remind about
naloxone co-prescribing for patients on
high dose or chronic opioids we have one
that i
really like which is when a patient is
discharged after a cesarean section or
vaginal delivery if they receive an
opioid when they come back to clinic it
reminds the provider to ask them if
they've finished using that medication
and to discard it if it's no longer
needed which it frequently isn't after
delivery
and then finally we have one in the
upper right corner which is puts all of
it together it checks to make sure that
the provider has looked at the
prescription drug monitoring program
takes to make sure that there's an
opiate agreement on file make sure that
there's not opioids and benzodiazepines
together and really it's just a holistic
view that's used whenever a patient
provider is refilling a prescription for
opioids
so those are just the basics and now
again i want to dive into three specific
advanced concepts
the first one is post-surgical opiate
prescriptions
this is probably the most common
post-operative complication and i know
it's a little bit unusual to hear that
because we think of things like
infection or readmission is the most
common
but if you look at this about seven
percent of patients who work on opioids
before their surgery will be on
long-term opioids after their surgery
that's life alternate alternating that
means that they're going to be on these
medications for a long time and so even
though we want to we want to well at the
same time we want to treat pain
compassionately and often that involves
the use of opioids we also don't want to
be stuck in a situation where the
patient is then dependent on them and
uses it far beyond when their pain is
expected to subside
in fact there was this meta-analysis
from 33 studies that did find that seven
percent of patients continued to fill
opioids more than three months after
surgery
the second one was actually pretty
pretty stunning
analysis of six studies found that
between 67 to 92 percent of
post-surgical patients
had opioids that were unused after their
surgery
so they took some of the pills but they
didn't finish them
and then we found that 42 to 71 percent
were entirely unused the patient didn't
even use the prescription at all
yet about 15 to 29 depending on the
study reported opioid-induced adverse
effects
this just makes the case that we need to
right-size how we use opioids after
surgery
at our hospital we've released
guidelines
this is the guidelines for
after general surgery i think you'll
find it's pretty interesting
after you get your appendix out the most
we give is 10 pills same with
gallbladder
for the bigger surgeries like colectomy
we give up to 20 pills
this is a big change from what we were
doing years ago where we were getting 30
60 or 90 pills after discharge but what
we found is that patients do really well
with this they often don't need more
than that and what happens is that after
the acute pain subsides they're fine
using non-opioid pain medications they
don't have them sitting around in the
medicine cabinet while the where they
can be diverted or they don't use them
excessively to the point where they
develop tolerance and then withdrawals
they stop using them
if you're going to embark on this
journey i want to share two different
resources with you the first is a great
program out of michigan called open
and you can just google michigan open
project
this is a very rigorous evidence-based
approach in which they looked at all
sorts of surgical procedures
they looked at the prescriptions that
patients got they interviewed the
patients before and after their
surgeries and their use of opioids and
they found that
patients often didn't need the large
numbers that were being prescribed
this group publishes their guidelines
their recommendations and they update it
every year as well so this is a really
good place for you to start
evidence-based
and then the final part to this is about
education
patients need to be informed that
they're going to have pain after surgery
our job is to make it bearable and
manageable and that it will improve
but not that it's going to take it away
completely it's it's realistic to think
that you will have
again your gallbladder
open colectomy and that you're going to
have zero pain so managing and tempering
expectations is important in a way that
patients can
be comfortable even with non-opiate
medications but they might not have zero
pain until they heal
we've created our own post-surgical
guidelines there's also a very good set
of guidelines at the american college of
surgeons and you can see that on the on
the page here and you can freely
download this it's a fantastic resource
and you can just plug this into your
instructions tomorrow and get started
shifting gears we're going to talk about
tapering of high dose opiate
prescriptions
this has been a controversial topic and
it needs to be done very thoughtfully
you've all heard about
the the challenges of opioids and what
the cause of the opioid epidemic the
quote unquote epidemic has been
and we know that early on in the
epidemic
it was often attributed to prescribed
pain medications the pain is the fifth
vital sign etc we've increased our
prescriptions for opioids which i'll
show you on the next slide
but i thought this chart really captures
this nicely
the yellow are deaths attributed to
prescribed opioids
the orange are deaths attributed to
heroin
and the red is death attributed to
synthetic opioids like fentanyl
and the really interesting thing here is
that you can see that
the you know although we put more
attention for for several years on
heroin and then particularly these past
four to five years on synthetic opioids
as being the lion's share of reasons for
for having overdose you can see that
that yellow the amount of yellow really
hasn't budged
so although we are seeing increased
deaths from heroin and fentanyl the
numbers of deaths from prescribed
opioids is staying the same and it
essentially means that we can't lose
sight and can't lose track of the
prescribed opioids
i thought this was a fascinating chart
this looks up through through 2020
through last year
this is the prescribed or actually the
dispensed
opioids in the united states from 1992
to 2020.
and it basically converted all the
opioids to morphine milligram
equivalents you can there's conversion
factors where you can convert any opioid
to an equivalent of morphine
you can see back in 1992 we prescribed
about 25 billion morphine milligram
equivalents in this country which is
quite a lot actually
but in 2011 we were at 10 times that
rate 250 billion morphine milligram
equivalents
since that we've had increased
recognition of the over prescribing of
these medications and there's been a
marked decrease
and you can see that we've we have the
pendulum hazard actually that has swung
back tremendously we're now to the level
that we were at around 2001 or so
so um it's going to be interesting to
see where we settle out from this um and
my hope is that we don't overshoot it
because i think it was clear that we
were under treating pain in the 90s and
then we over treated it in the early
2000s we'll see where we settle
but if you actually look at the
prescriptions
for different doses you can see
something interesting the first is that
the total and this is from 2011 to 2019
decreased by about 50 percent
but the majority the the larger number
largest number of prescriptions that
decreased were for those of greater than
90 more few milligram equivalents today
per day they decreased by about 70
and probably the reason for this are the
cdc guidelines
in particular the cdc guidelines in 2016
came out said for non-cancer chronic
pain
you should avoid prescriptions over 90
mm per day unless there is careful
consideration and justification
at our hospital what that meant was that
we actually had a mandate from our
hospital board of directors to avoid a
high-dose prescriptions
when this happened they came to me as
the director of the opiate stewardship
program and said fix this
meanwhile i know that we have legacy
patients we have patients that were on
high-dose opioids well before the 2016
guidelines so we had to figure out what
to do
first thing was we looked backwards we
looked at from 2018 to 19 we had about
77 000 pill form op prescriptions
written
and about 15.7 percent were for more
than 90 more female grammatical ones
today per day and just that was very
eye-opening for us we didn't realize
that we had so many that were for high
dose and i would encourage you all to do
the same at your systems
but then when we drilled down deeper
we found that just two clinics were
responsible for nearly half of all of
that prescribing
and so we instantly knew where our
target was and again this is an example
of looking at the data and how that can
help you
so what we did is for those two clinics
we rolled out a comprehensive program
first of all starting in july 2019 our
trainees and fellows were prohibited for
writing opiate prescriptions for more
than 90 more for milligram of course per
day this basically did two things the
first is it did make it slightly more
inconvenient for the attending doctors
who then had how to write the
prescription and how to think about it
but it also set the stage for our
trainees that is no longer okay to write
these prescriptions
and i know this is controversial because
there are a lot of patients that have
chronic non-cancer pain that are on
these medications
and they they
need these medications to survive and to
to function
but we have found that if you do this in
a compassionate way the majority of
those patients can be tapered to safer
levels
and hopefully it should go without
saying that we know that the risk of
overdose death being on more than 90 to
100 more milligram coins a day is about
10 times higher than those who are on
much lower doses under 40 more milligram
equivalents today per day so it is it is
a safety issue for the patient it is a
best practice
so in addition to preventing
prescriptions for opioids at high doses
for our trainees we also promulgated
system-wide best practices as part of
those guidelines i mentioned before a
prescription drug monitoring program
check prior to every prescription
naloxone co-prescriptions for those on
chronic opioids pain treatment agreement
for everyone on chronic opioids
random toxicology screening at least
once a year
clinic visit every every three months
we rolled out safe tapering
recommendations
we avoided opioids of benzos and made
sure that they were not prescribed in
combination
and then we performed random chart
reviews every month to make sure that
the providers were following these
guidelines
we then shared the prescribing practices
with their peers so we could normalize
and tell people where where they're at
similar to what i mentioned from the
from the previous metric tools
we have a dedicated pharmacist who is
there to help safely tape her patients
she's wonderful she's passionate about
this and she actually has prescriptive
authority so she can write prescriptions
and really takes out
the the middleman essentially because
she can say we're going to be very
evidence-based very very algorithmic
about your paper and again not make
patients feel like they're being singled
out
we offered psychosocial support for
patients with difficulty with the papers
rapid access to psychiatry
rapid access to our substance use
disorder bridge clinic which i'll talk
about at the end of this talk and we had
monthly meetings with our chief medical
officer compliance and other leaders
and we're really pleased with the
results on this chart you can see the
blue the blue columns are prescriptions
for less than 90 morphe milligram
equivalents per day and the red columns
are those for 90 more milligram
equivalents per day and from when we
started doing the paper you can see a
marked decrease in the number of
of the the high dose opioids and not
much of a change of the lower dose
opioids which we're happy with we're
fine with
one thing to note though is that the the
after the intervention this is about 18
months of data
this is not something that's going to
happen overnight this is actually
something that takes place over months
frequently you're going to taper
around 10 percent of the dose per month
and that can be a long paper if a
patient is already on very high doses of
opioids
so for us we did find that this
multi-faceted multidisciplinary model
could safely reduce the numbers of
high-dose prescriptions and it can take
months it's also not appropriate for all
patients but we we try and justify when
it's not appropriate and we try and make
that a small number of patients
we want to find out what happened to
some of the patients that dropped out
that no longer were followed at the
clinic we don't know if there were
unintentional overdoses but our
preliminary analysis shows that there
were not
we
the provider experience too because i
think this was a big change for a lot of
the providers
we also started to look at the patient
experience and we actually look back at
our patient
uh the surveys that are sent out to
patients after their visits and
unfortunately the vast majority of them
are satisfied
because we found that with this approach
patients do understand it they do see
the news as well they do see that
high-dose opioids are dangerous they're
also motivated and actually frequently
we do see functional improvements in
pain
for our patients after they're they're
off of the high doses
that's a small warning though this paper
came out just a couple months ago
and showed that looking at a large
commercial insurance data set for
patients that did have tapers they saw
increases in the numbers of overdoses
and mental health crises associated with
those decreases in doses
now this paper was unable to look at
what else was offered such as the
psychosocial support that i mentioned
before but i just want to highlight that
these are unintentional consequences
that can be
the patients can have if you do embark
on a program like this needs to be done
very thoughtfully and you need to
embrace the patient and make sure they
have all the services they need
including for patients that that have
exacerbations of depression when they
stop their opioids or those that truly
do have opioid use disorder that need
addiction treatment in addition to their
pain treatment
and that brings us to the third
advanced concept which is substance use
disorder treatment
at our hospital i'm really proud of the
model that we we implemented which was
after a couple of other models that
happened throughout the country most
notably there was landmark work from
yale university which showed that if you
were able to start a patient who
presented to the emergency department
with withdrawal or seeking help for
their opioids on medication for opioid
use disorder such as suboxone or
buprenorphine
and get them into a clinic within the
next
24 to 72 hours next business day and
have them follow up you can over you can
you more than double their chances of
being
in active treatment at one month
the numbers went from around 30
to more than 70 percent
there's very little things in medicine
which are so effective so much effective
as this
and so we've we've adopted that same
model we have a bridge clinic it
basically will take patients on a
walk-in basis and an on-demand basis we
prefer that they do have an appointment
um you know we'll also do telehealth
especially in the age of coded but you
know what if a patient is still actively
using drugs
that's okay we just want to be able to
engage with them we want to be able to
share harm reduction resources with them
we want to be able to help them and when
they're ready when they're ready for
recovery we're there for them
and this model works because we know
that if you take a patient and
withdrawal and you tell them make an
appointment two weeks from thursday it's
not going to happen because the drugs
have hydra hijacked their brain and
they're not able to to do that so
patients do need a bridge
our bridge clinic has addiction
psychiatrists
medicine internal medicine physician
there's an id doctor on staff that
handles infectious disease complications
there are
case managers
care transition specialists that help
with long-term placement and it's just
been a very successful model that i
would encourage all of you to pursue
we've also another part of this was
getting prescribers to have their waiver
to prescribe buprenorphine as many of
you know that there previously was an
eight training course that was required
for
physicians that were prescribing
buprenorphine to their patients in a
24-hour
course for
advanced practice practitioners such as
nurse practitioners and physician
assistants
fortunately this past march those
training requirements went away
you still have to apply for the waiver
but at least you don't have to do long
training and that's to prescribe it to
30 patients at a time so this works for
the vast majority of our providers
whether they be in the emergency
department or in the hospital and that
was very helpful for us to be able to
get people waivered and also educate
them at the same time
and really the the innovative part of
this that i'm really proud of that i
didn't see coming but has has really
been transformational
is the idea that we can get people
started on medication for opioid use
disorder treatment
again buprenorphine most commonly
while they're in the hospital for
medical complications of injection drug
use
and we can send them home with a picc
line or a long-term indwelling
catheter
so the the prototypical patient would be
someone who had injected drugs they had
a bloodstream infection goes to their
heart and they get endocarditis they
typically need to need to be on about
six weeks of iv antibiotics
unfortunately the oral antibiotics just
don't work as well and iv is better
previously no one felt comfortable
sending those patients home with a picc
line in place because there was fear
that they would then inject through
their picc line
what we found is that if we can engage
patients while they're in the hospital
get them started on treatment have them
see a recovery coach
then have them follow up in the bridge
clinic at least twice a week afterwards
they can safely go home with a picc line
it's not for everybody we have to make
sure that they have stable housing
there's not active drug use in the house
that they've got transportation to come
back to the clinic that they're stable
on the medication before they leave the
hospital
but
our patients are very honest with us and
they tell us
we're not stupid i know that i might
have an addiction to drugs but i'm not
going to inject
drugs into this line that i know is
going directly into my heart
others have told us if i need to access
a vein to inject drugs i know how to do
that i don't need the pickling to do
that
so it's been a it's been a change it's
been uncomfortable for a lot of us but
we found through studies like this one
which you can you can look up or you can
reach out to me for a copy of that
patients actually do well with it
again not for everybody and it's not
perfect
we had 15 of patients relapse with our
initial cohort relapse is a part of
recovery and it's expected so that's not
failure that just means that we were we
know that a certain percentage will
relapse and we're there to help help
them when we can and when they're there
when they do relapse
the biggest sell for you for your
hospital your health system is days in
the hospital because previously we had
lots of difficulty
being able to transition these patients
to a rehab facility because many of them
wouldn't take patients with active
substance use disorder and so our
patients would end up going to the two
rehab facilities that would take
patients and we were told repetitively
that drug use there was rampant so it's
actually much worse for them to go to
these rehab facilities it's safer for
them to go home
another project we're working on is for
a pathway for patients that are admitted
with cardiac surgery you might have
heard this as well in the news of
patients that have cardiac surgery
because their valve became infected and
no longer works they have an open heart
surgery to fix their valve and then they
relapse reuse again and then
they need a repeat surgery
or when they're in the hospital we're so
focused on repairing their valve that we
don't treat the underlying issue we
don't treat the substance use disorder
which
is very is very unusual for me because
like if you have diabetes
and you might have a diabetic fluid
infection we don't just treat the
infection and not treat the underlying
diabetes
same thing with substance use disorders
so if we rolled out a pathway in which
we we have our nurses have a consistent
message we have communication with the
team so there's not splitting of
different providers or there's not
patients who come
who are told different things by
different providers we've actually
rolled this out this training out in our
simulation center and we've enacted
cases with our with our teams it's been
really successful
um and the last two things i want to
just mention are first about substitute
about national recovery month and the
final one is about stigma
national recovery month happens every
september and for us this is the time
when we reboot our initiatives we have
the majority of our of our information
booths our tables you can see there are
a picture on the top with two of our
recovery coaches
we have trainings like you can see in
the bottom we're doing a narcan training
session for for people in the hospital
that were walking by a highly trafficked
area
we have an exhibit a photojournalistic
exhibit about recovery
and then finally the one on the right
was a very moving exhibit we had this
year we planted purple flags one for
every life lost in our state in 2020 we
put it right on the main lawn in front
of the the original part of our hospital
things like this are a good moment to
spotlight recovery
and i would encourage you to embrace
this
there's a lot of materials available
online that you can you can use for your
own efforts
um and it again is a way to really
highlight this disease and that it is
treatable that recovery is possible
and the final part i want to mention is
just about stigma
unlike most any other disease
the stigma with this one is very
burdensome and we know that it's very
detrimental to care for patients who are
seeking help
and unlike other diseases where if you
say someone is diabetic it's not that
big of a deal
if you tell someone a medical
professional telling a patient that
they're an addict
it's a very it's
it's very hurtful to them it's um
it's putting a stigmatizing language on
that patient
we say that with other language as well
such as if you have a toxicology screen
that comes back positive and you call it
dirty
that implies that the patient is dirty
same thing if you say someone is clean
then what's the opposite of clean is
dirty so we really do things think that
words matter
there is a language that's used for
patients that are in recovery and they
might go to a narcotics anonymous
meeting and say that they are an addict
or they're an alcoholic and that that's
okay if they want to identify like that
with those words as part of their
recovery we should support that but as
medical professionals we need to be more
careful and so we rolled out a hospital
without stigma pledge you can see the
the terms there we're happy to share
this as well it's also available on our
website we just remind staff that this
this the words do matter with this
disease
and with that i'll conclude
um i'm happy to answer any questions you
might have by email that's my email
address there
please go to our websites we have two
one is b cord at brighamwomens.org which
has a lot of these
these guidelines
poppy.bwh.harvard.edu is our program in
opioid and pain innovation you can learn
about some of the work that we're doing
there and i also provided qr codes which
will get you directly to our opioid
prescribing guidelines and our opioid
tapering guidelines
i hope this was a helpful talk for you i
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference and thank you so much for
your attention